Droht uns ein Superflare, ein Sonnensturm,
der Plasmawolken in Richtung Erde jagt und
das weltweite Stromnetz extrem beschädigt
und unsere gesamte Telekommunikation bedroht
. Das hätte mit fatale Folgen, beispielsweise
für die Welt-Wirtschaft.
Ein japanisches Astronomie-Team hat jetzt
herausgefunden, dass auch sonnenähnliche
Sterne besonders extreme Stürme - sogenannte
“Superflares”- produzieren können.
Hunderte bis tausende Male stärker, als alles
was wir bisher erlebt haben.
Und das schon relativ bald.
Clixoom Science & Fiction Hier gibt es täglich
faszinierende Science-Videos, abonniert den
Kanal, nur dann verpasst ihr nichts.
Herzlich willkommen!
Der Sonnensturm von 1859 ging in die Geschichte
ein: Die ausgestoßene Materie von mehreren
starken Sonneneruptionen erreichte nach etwa
17 Stunden die Erde - und zwar mit einer Geschwindigkeit
von mehr als 2000 km/s.
Starkströme zerstörten Telegrafenleitungen
und das gesamte Netz, das gerade erst installiert
worden war, wurde enorm beschädigt.
Forschungsteams weltweit sind mit Hochdruck
dabei, mehr Details über Sonneneruptionen
zu erfahren.
Klar ist: Bei solch einem Ausbruch wird Plasma
ins All geschleudert und dabei wird energiereiche
Strahlung frei - sogenannte “Flares”.
Das Problem: Solche Ausbrüche sind nicht
wirklich vorauszusehen.
Doch die Signale einer Sonneneruption erreichen
die Erde innerhalb von etwa acht Minuten.
Japanische Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftler
haben jetzt neue super spannende Erkenntnisse
zum Thema gesammelt.
Das Team hatte 43 sonnenähnliche Sterne,
bei denen zuvor bereits Superflares beobachtet
werden konnten, mit dem Gaia-Weltraumteleskop
und einem amerikanischen Teleskop genauer
ins Visier genommen.
Bei ihrer Analyse ging es darum, wie oft Superflares
vorkommen, wie alt die jeweiligen Sterne sind
und ob es sich bei ihnen tatsächlich um Einzelsterne
handelt.
Und das Ergebnis ist überraschend: Denn der
japanischen Studie zufolge kommen Superflares
eben NICHT nur bei jungen Sternen vor.
Stattdessen ist dieses Phänomen auch bei
älteren, langsam rotierenden Sternen zu beobachten...sprich
der Sonne.
- Allerdings sind die Strahlenausbrüche dann
nicht ganz so gewaltig.
Junge Sterne aber produzieren Superflares
mit einer Energie von ACHTUNG - 100 Milliarden
Petajoule: Hier sind also besonders extreme
Strahlenausbrüche zu beobachten.
Schon frühere Beobachtungen mit Weltraumteleskopen
hatten gezeigt, dass schnell rotierende junge
Sterne gigantische Strahlenausbrüche produzieren
können.
Die aktuelle Studie bestätigt dies nun.
Die Analyse der japanischen Fachleute zeigt
aber auch, dass extreme Superflares bei der
Sonne und bei anderen sonnenähnlichen Sternen
auch vorkommen, aber eher selten.
Dazu heißt es in der Studie: “Bei sonnenähnlichen
Sternen im Alter von rund 4,6 Milliarden Jahren
würden Superflares dieser Stärke etwa alle
2.000 bis 3.000 Jahre einmal auftreten“.
Auch, wenn unsere Sonne sich demnach meistens
nicht wirklich extrem verhält, ist ihr Magnetfeld
- anders als bislang angenommen - also keineswegs
zu schwach, um gewaltige Superflares zu produzieren.
Entwarnung für das Leben auf der Erde bedeutet
das keineswegs - im Gegenteil.
Denn auch Flares mit einer “lediglich”
100- bis 1000-fachen Stärke gewöhnlicher
Flares können fatale Folgen für unsere Zivilisation
mit sich bringen..
Im Angesicht dieser Bedrohung sind wir allerdings
äußerst schlecht auf einen möglichen nächsten
Sonnensturm vorbereitet.
Forschungsteams weltweit versuchen also notgedrungen,
über Statistiken und Simulationen heraus
zu kristallisieren, wie häufig und wie schlimm
Sonnenstürme uns in der Erdgeschichte bereits
getroffen haben.
Radioaktive Baumringe legen nahe, dass in
den Jahren 775 und 994 gigantische Teilchenwellen
über die Erde hinweggefegt sein müssen.
Auch die Analyse des Lichts von knapp 150.000
sonnenähnlichen Sternen, konnte der Wissenschaftswelt
etwas über die Häufigkeit solcher Stürme
verraten.
Eine weitere gewaltige Strahlendusche aus
dem All bekam die Erde wohl auch vor knapp
7.500 Jahren ab.
Das japanische Forschungsteam geht mit großer
Sicherheit davon aus, dass es sich damals
um extreme Sonnenflares gehandelt haben muss.
Doch wie groß ist das Risiko, dass sich ein
solches Ereignis in naher Zukunft wiederholt?!
Laut des japanischen Astronoms Yuta Notsu
ist der nächste Superflare der Sonne nur
eine Frage der Zeit: “Es besteht durchaus
die Möglichkeit, dass wir ein solches Ereignis
in den nächsten 100 Jahren oder so erleben
werden.”
Nochmal zum Mitschreiben: In den nächsten
100 Jahren könnten uns so ein Supersonnensturm
erreichen und Stromnetze, Telekommunikation
usw. und ernsthaft beschädigen.
Es könnte Wochen und Monate dauern bis alles
wieder funktioniert.
Die Weltwirtschaft könnten großen Schaden
nehmen.
Aktienkurse einbrechen, Banken pleite gehen.
Es könnte absolut dramatische Folgen haben.
Diese Erkenntnisse verdeutlichen noch einmal
wie dringend notwendig es ist, dass wir die
Prozesse auf der Sonne besser verstehen..
Denn nur so können wir sie auch irgendwann
einmal vorhersagen.
Zwar sehen Teleskope und erdnahe Satelliten
den Ausbruch der Sonne, doch dann muss auch
eingeschätzt werden, wie stark er ausfallen
wird und ob er die Erde überhaupt treffen
wird.
Erst 20 Minuten, bevor der Sturm die Erde
erreicht, ist dann auch klar, in welche Richtung
sein Magnetfeld zeigen wird.
Und das ist entscheidend dafür, wie gut er
das irdische Magnetfeld durchdringen wird.
Derzeit spielen wir quasi russisches Roulette
mit der Sonne.
Die europäische Raumsonde “Solar Orbiter”,
die im Februar 2020 aufbrechen soll, wird
uns mehr Informationen liefern.
Aber dann müssen wir auch Konsequenzen ziehen
und die Strom- und Kommunikationsnetze gegen
solche solaren Superstürme sicher machen.
Wie groß ist eigentlich die Sonne?
Größenvergleich Sonnensystem in einem coolen
Comic bei Astro Comics TV.
Anklicken, anschauen und auf jeden Fall Abonnieren.
Bis dann bleibt dran!